[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui eric 9
pour son nouveau roman rentrée
littéraire et olivier goujon qui publie
pitcairn les révoltés du bounty vont
disparaître une enquête dans la plus
petite entité politique du monde moins
de 50 habitants tous descendants des
fameux mutinés du xviiie siècle mais
commençons d'abord par les images que
vous avez choisi tous les deux pour
illustrer notre époque ça sert et votre
livier goujon il faut vous nous
l'expliquer je vais vous expliquer ce
état c'est une icône enfin c'est une
oeuvre moderne travaillait avec les
principes de l'iconographie du 11e en
ukraine c'est une oeuvre de d'oksana
chache co qui est la fondatrice du
mouvement des femen en ukraine et que tu
es une immense et qui vous avez consacré
un livre j'ai consacré un livre à
l'espoir des semaines et à la manière
dont le mouvement s'est égaré
une des deux grandes fondatrice du
mouvement des semaines et c'était une
immense artiste qui détournait
des icônes mais avec une main un
artisanat une façon traditionnelle
c'est-à-dire qu'elle travaillait des
icônes comme on travaille les icônes au
11e mais elles y mettaient un sens
politique assez puissant et là en
l'occurrence il s'agit de deux
d'une critique des réseaux sociaux et de
la société capitaliste à partir de la
religion voilà la vôtre eric 9
c'est une galette des rois on reste un
peu dans le droit fil alors c'est un
clin d'oeil parce que c'est au train où
ça va peut-être qu'on pourra plus manger
des galettes des rois bientôt pourquoi
avec parce que c'est en référence au
hamas ah vous voyez ouais je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que c'était plutôt un
retour de la religion que
j'aurais pu prendre une religieuse
voilà c'est ça tombe à la bonne date oui
c'est ça surtout que c'est ce que tout
le monde a mangé aujourd'hui et bien
commençons
[Musique]
deinove vous êtes écrivain vous avez
publié votre premier roman précautions
d'usagé en 1982 vous étiez l'un des
premiers de votre génération avec
patrick besson et didier van cauwelaert
michel houellebecq à l'époque travail
est encore dans l'informatique
aujourd'hui paraît chez albin michel
votre trentième livre il s'intitule
rentrée littéraire c'est un roman est
alors sur le quatrième de couverture on
peut lire pierre heckler sont éditeurs
en ce début de 21e siècle un grand
groupe s'intéresse à leur maison la
vendre ont-ils point d'interrogation est
acquis point d'interrogation alors on
pourrait croire qu'il s'agit d'un
western financiers 1 mais en réalité
cette intrigue n'occupe que quelques
lignes quand l'hymne vos héros se fiche
pas mal de cuba les a achetés comme ils
se fichent de savoir à quel livre iront
les prix littéraire de la rentrée
c'est cv albin michel votre éditeur qui
s'est dit merde qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire sur le quatrième de couv bas la
poste moi qui étais obligé de faire ça
n'est pas par quel bout ses boutiques et
ses attentes que qu'il va y avoir à
suspense le double si vous en avez été
complètement un petit peu mais c'était
pour
trouver un décor parce que je me suis
aperçu qu'ils aient pas tant de remous
que ça qui se passait dans le milieu de
l'édition c'est vrai et je trouvais ça
intéressant parce que c'est une
profession qui est en train de changer à
la vitesse grand v et ça m'intéressait
de mettre un couple uni et jamais
divorcé dans ce milieu quand même assez
remuant tumultueux où la qualité la
règle est de voir un éditeur qui se
moquait de la modernité des prix
littéraires en face ils en avaient un
sale ne le tiendrai pas et qui n'en
voyaient pas de service de presse aux
blogueuses qui se fichait de tout ça et
qui se disent ils est rachetée peut-être
sa lassitude cents à combler alors
seront en effet des sexagénaires
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il faut
dix ans de moins que l'orage 1 ils sont
éditeurs mais ils passent leur temps à
table avec des avec des riders ils
s'ennuient à peu près avec tout le monde
en plus t'as couple fidèle vais dire il
ne leur arrive donc strictement rien
c'est notre vie nous avait voulu faire
un roman sur la fin du désir la voiture
non parce qu'il continuait à
s'émerveiller d'être ensemble mais c'est
quand même le milieu de l'édition ils en
connaissent tous les tours et les
détours donc et plus rien ne peut les
surprendre et c'est peut-être aussi la
fin d'un monde pour c et puis des ailes
et vous parlez des déchaînés des
restaurants mais c'est quand même là où
se concentre l'essentiel du boulot dans
l'édition ces lignes à basse et le seul
métier on travaille uniquement entre 1h
et de quatre heures de l'après midi et
puis retomber plus les éditeurs vous
parle des livres qu'ils soient obligés
de réécrire entièrement je parle pas des
vôtres mais mais j'aimerais qu'ils le
fassent
général mais la plupart des livres qui
nécessite d un travail de réécriture
considérable et paraît même certains
moments on d'ailleurs faut pas se fier
non mais ça c'est un livre qui veut
défendre le papier c'est ça parle de
toutes ces boutiques qui sont en train
de fermer les librairies les les
restaurants les cinémas c'est une ode à
à paris qu'on aimait parce que je
voulais que ce soit un livre très
parisien dans tous les sens du terme
d'ailleurs mais comme on voit beaucoup
d'endroits de new york dans les films de
woody allen mais c'est un roman de stade
j qu'un vous euros par le docteur
billets de boîte de nuit qui ont fermé
depuis longtemps avec un moment donné où
le héros récapitule tous les endroits
qui ont fermé
mais est-ce que ça n'est pas le problème
de tous les gens âgés qui survivent dans
un pays où dans un milieu professionnel
qui ne ressemble plus à celui qu'ils
avaient connue peut-être
mais c'est pas grave la nostalgie c'est
pas un défaut ce faux pas que ça bascule
dans la mélancolie noir est complète
mais la nostalgie en plus pour un roman
c'est quand même un carburant de
regretter les choses qu'on a perdu c'est
celle à la ferme africaine ces quelques
mots sont pas nostalgique parce qu'ils
ne sont plus assez puissant s'il faisait
encore la loi il serait moins
nostalgique celle citée michel
houellebecq qui à l'époque vous sortiez
votre premier roman travailler encore
dans l'informatique luxueux que lui les
pas de style chic si vous laissez
maintenant qui règne les années 80 il a
payé de passer devant un bureau oui mais
il a travaillé dans sa vie contrairement
à moi
il n'a pas être nostalgique de ces
horaires de bureau alors que nous
baissons et compagnie on s'est
débrouillé pour ne pas faire être en
lice depuis 40 ans voilà écrire des
livres et en livres pour moi c'est pas
du travail c'est un plaisir chahut
certains livres croyez moi c'est du
travail oui oui c'est vrai mais on peut
les laisser tomber très vite c'est ça
l'avantagé
est ce que vous êtes sûr que vos
personnages s'ennuie autant que vous le
dites j'ai l'impression moi qu'il faut
sur blanc bon il s'ennuie pas mais ils
sont pas dupes il ya des moments où je
me dois de dire qu'ils s'ennuient bah
oui parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de razer dans le milieu de deux jurés
qu'il faut convaincre de voter pour la
maison en question de fond que les kovac
faut les acheter des prix ce que vous
dites mais oui mais on peut plus le
faire ça maintenant hélas moi je
regrette la bonne vieille corruption des
années 80 quand les jurés touchaient des
avaloirs pour des livres qui ne sont
jamais mais aujourd'hui hélas la société
tellement cadré que ce serait impossible
techniquement se seraient considérées
comme des salaires fictifs et d'asthme
c'est ça que je regrettais et que les
les éditeurs et les éditrices
aujourd'hui à table prennent une salade
verte et un quart de badoit au lieu de
commander un avis ou les sushis la poule
6 de paris ou des graines tous les
sushis vivre ça sur les attachés de
presse de l'édition de chances des
personnages légendaires qui restait à
table avec les écrivains qui parlait de
tout sauf de littérature qui s'entendait
bien il y avait des gens comme ça alors
il s'ennuie beaucoup vos personnages et
ils sont souvent épuisées et il ya leurs
amis aussi écrivain conduit épuisé tout
le temps parce qu'il sort beaucoup c'est
qu'il a beaucoup d'aventurés mais ils
sont peut-être épuisé parce qu'ils sont
fidèles lui il était plus si c'est balla
surcroît d'énergie mais vous êtes choqué
les fidèles elle parce que moi j y crois
pas du tout et sa fidélité ban avait
d'après ce que vous dites bien comme
elle est elle peut pas se contenter
d'aller au restaurant et au cinéma avec
son my donc l'art et le trompe bah
peut-être ce sera dans le tome 2 1 dans
rentrée littéraire fait du symbolique et
il s'est ensuite parce qu'il est razer
il y les rasoirs à vous trouver oui oh
mais peut-être qu'il préfère la
compagnie de ses copains à celle de
savoie il s'ennuie partout où il va au
resto ouais mais il aime bien partir en
vacances ensemble shesivan qu'il dit
ouais rien ne dit que ce soit moi vous
savez je n'ai pas lu les bras c'est sa
faiblesse on peut être parfois du peu
des personnages qu'on a créé en tout cas
on s'est dit tiens je les crée comme ça
mais en fait après quand les hôtes élise
il n'y a pas du tout ce qu'on croyait
rebat sans doute moi j'aurais aimé être
comme eux
plus angoissés vous êtes moins heureux
en ménage bah moi sauf cediv ans et
plusieurs fois de ses jamais plafond
peut être on peut tomber sur la mer mais
c'est un vrai roman pour ça on peut se
résoudre à son sort à wemmel a eu la
chance et qu'ils ont fait ça dès le
début mais c'est pour ça que c'est une
fiction mais à part le fait de faire un
roman sur l'édition on va en parler
effectivement quelques l'édition a pu
changer qu'est ce qui vous a attiré
parce que vous avez pu faire un roman
sur l'édition où justement ce serait un
western financiers on aurait dû
suspectes sur saint-andré qui valait
racheter est-ce qu'ils vont avoir le
prix goncourt est ce qu'il va arriver à
acheter les jurés qu'ils ont pas le
droit d'acheter etc non pas du tout au
final je voulais raconter quoi une
histoire d'amour dans un milieu où elles
sont rares c'était pour ça or tous les
milieux nous allons dans l'édition c'est
quand même heure la trahison qui règne
vous savez il ya des tout un tas de
procès entre éditeurs de deux d'auteur
qui quitte une maison alors qu'ils
avaient signé un contrat mais il ya
beaucoup de couples à la tête de maisons
d'édition parce que c'est un couple non
très très peu très peu d'ailleurs oui je
vois pas d'exemple
mail à la maison c'est pas un milieu si
tu entends vous le décrivez comme vous
dites à côté littéraire il ya que des
vieilles filles à lunettes et des
barbies chu avec des pellicules sur les
épaules mais ça c'est un peu la
caricature pour s'amuser oui mais c'est
non mais de toute façon il ya plus de
cocktails nulle part il ya plus de fait
il ya plus de gratuité les gens sont
terriblement sérieux pas seulement dans
l'édition la c1 un milieu on devait
aller pour pour s'amuser pour pour vivre
une vie un peu à la la filiale dallas
bernard francou à l'asag en c2 c'est
peut-être le livre le regret de cet
univers sagan est qui existaient qui
n'existe plus du tout parce que les les
gens maintenant font écrivains comme
ailier il ferait dentiste mais françoise
sagan a eu l'intelligence tout surtout
reid tas de gens qui n'étaient pas du
tout dans le milieu littéraire c'est
plutôt etc cela qu'elle est qu'avec les
autres c'était déjà en frivole qui
aimait la fête qui n'aimait pas
travailler et surtout qui avait de
l'humour qui ne se prenait pas au
sérieux et ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qui est en train de fondre comme neige
au soleil les prises de tête qu'on a
maintenant dans dans l'édition c'est
alors que c'est une chance inouïe d'être
dans ce milieu là et là on a
l'impression que c'est grave que tout
est important alors que tout le monde
s'en fout des vivres c'est ça qui est
bien c'est quoi qui le chiffre
d'affaires de l'édition française c'est
l'équivalent de croix dans les étages où
deux des galeries lafayette ah oui
sûrement mais un un patron de pme pour
lui un goncourt c'est dérisoire et
d'ailleurs si un patron de pme dirigeait
sa sa boîte comme un éditeur s'occupe de
sa maison il fait faillite en six mois
mais c'est ça qui est bien aussi que
cette édition ne soit un truc un peu
libre et foutraque oui les goujons vous
connaissez ap l'édition vous avez publié
des livres j'ai publié des livres et
puis on en parle un petit peu de tout à
l'heure je fais le lien avec avec ce qui
se passe en italie parce que j'habite
entre paris et milan et
je vois bien que
la concentration nui à
la production et à la diversité de la
production que la disparition des
petites maisons d'édition
est un danger mais on parle toujours de
la disparition des petites maisons
d'édition que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
pas partout c'est donc je connais pas
tout le temps de maisons d'édition je ne
connaissais pas il ya peut-être là dure
pas très longtemps qu elles sont
minuscules les maisons dans des petits
voyages en minuscule non parce qu'il ya
quand même eu une époque où gaston
gallimard publiait des gens qui se
détestent entre eux et ça aujourd'hui
c'est inenvisageable vous imaginez chez
marion un livre qui dit du mal de
houellebecq ça ne serait jamais publié
oui et il ya plus ça maintenant et en
plus dans les grands groupes on en
parlait tout à l'heure avant l'émission
si m chez un éditeur du groupe quelqu'un
attaque un auteur d'une autre maison
s'est coincé à la base alors que ça
devrait être la liberté
oui il ya un raisonnement d'entreprise
quoi oui mais alors j'ai l'impression
aussi que ce sont les commerciaux les
htc ou sup de co dont on n'a pas voulu
dans les vrais boîte qui vont dans
l'édition donc c'est ni les lettres ni
les chiffres c'est et on voit le
résultat parce que le la qualité est en
train de baisser les et puis le système
français est très pervers avec les
offices auprès des libraires qui
achètent les livres et qui les renvoie
pour être remboursé donc c'est sans fin
c'est de la cavalerie permanent c'est
pour ça qu'il ya autant de livres qui
sortent d'ailleurs et c'est aussi parce
que c'est une économie de l'offre plus
vous sortez livres ou de films
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
films français qui sortent la plupart ne
sont vus par personne mais plus il ya
d'offres plus vous avez une chance
d'avoir un succès ah ouais mais s'est
noyé dans la masse 1 il y en a quand
même beaucoup d'autres à financer à côté
oui mais ça coûte rien livrer mais il
n'y a pas encore un intermittent de la
littérature dans l'édition ça viendra
peut-être le tipi dit s'écrit pas mais
je dois être payé d'un feuillet plupart
des gens ne vivent pas de leur écriture
vous avez toujours les journalistes
critiques de cinéma écrivain plupart des
gens travaillent dans l'édition dans la
presse - ou en un vrai boulot ouais mais
d'ailleurs c'est ça la perversité du
système aussi c'est que beaucoup
d'éditeurs sont aussi critiques ce
appartiennent à des jurys et une espèce
de constance m oui voilà le genre de
travail oui mais il ya même plus le
charmant que savez maintenant ce sont un
peu des est-ce que ça n'est pas une
fausse le stage dès aujourd'hui on se
dit oui il avait plus de talent je parle
pas des écrivains mais mais les
critiques les ai dit on les voit comme
des personnages plus à la fois plus
flamboyant mais aussi du talent mais
est-ce que ça n'est pas je pense que
d'abord il y avait autant de minables à
l'époque qu'aujourd'hui à non mais enfin
je sais pas il y avait quand même des
gens comme jean claude fasquelle chez
grasset rené julliard dans la maison qui
portait son nom gallimard bernard
grasset c'était quand même des grands
bonshommes tout ça qui avec il disait
peut-être pas tout mais qui avait un
flair absolue et qui savait comment
faire marcher
leur maison publiés lalita durs qu'ils
aimaient et gagnez de l'argent avec des
best-sellers et ce qui est un peu triste
aussi c'est qu'aujourd'hui les la
littérature ne dit plus rien à personne
moi je me souviens quand j'étais gamin
tout le monde savait qui était robert
sabatier bernard clavel pour citer des
gens si ça vous fait penser de moi
mais aujourd'hui à part ou helbecque
personne ne peut citer le nom d'un
écrivain depuis la mort de sagan ou de
jean d'ormesson ça c'est quand même
beaucoup à face et des radars c'est
comme le cinéma qui a disparu aussi des
des conversations dans les dînettes mais
avant tout le monde avait vu les mêmes
films sont en galère on peut l'expliquer
à la fois parce qu'aujourd'hui chacun a
son domaine est en fait vos enfants
écoutent une musique qui n'a rien à voir
avec la vôtre et dont vous n'avez jamais
entendu la moindre note ce qui
n'existait pas quand on était plus
jeunes ont regardé tous les trois mêmes
chaînes de télévision aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas donc chacun aide rsa
et dans sa chapelle
c'est ce qui peut expliquer qu'au fond
il ya plus de tubes de l'été parce que
tout le monde a le sien oui il ya plus
de stars paix et à notre époque il
n'était pas envisageable d'entendre une
chanson qui avait plus de six mois alors
aujourd'hui les gamins écoute pink floyd
ou les rolling stones comme si ça venait
de sortir ça ça aussi est-ce que vous
avez l'impression vous d'être en
concurrence là au mois de janvier avec
des romans parus il ya à 30 ou 40 ans ou
50 ans vous êtes en concurrence avec
stendhal ou
non mais j'aime je trouve que stendhal
ça serait bien qu'ils publient en
cependant là je l'aiderai sera une bonne
critique parce que quand dans la musique
qu'ils aiment ça on est désormais disque
aujourd'hui vous êtes en concurrence
voilà et ça ça existe vous n'allez pas
chercher les on va aller on pouvait y
retrouver les vieux disent non nous les
passait pas la radio avril c'était
l'équivalent en voilà non mais
heureusement le et c'est pareil avec
lucienne aujourd'hui les films attendent
qu'on veuille bien les regarder ils sont
ils sont stockés alors que les livres
c'est l'ardoisé magique tiens c'est
facile tout c'est pire que les yaourts
ça durera à peine trois semaines alors
quand vous assistez beaucoup dans ce
livre sur les fées thibault ce qui a
changé dans l'édition depuis que vous
êtes entré en tant qu'écrivain fils
alban d'ay parce que je n'ai jamais été
étonnant donc en 82 vous devez des
écrivains et c'était vraiment ça n'avait
rien à voir ah ouais la table ronde dans
laquelle vous avez vous aviez publié
précautions d'usagé ça n'a plus rien à
voir avec ce que ce qu'est albin michel
ou jour du pagne bassin aux métiers de
demain michel scène maison énorme
la table ronde s'était plaint de la
comedd
la maison de négoce à réussir deux
blondes et ça c'était l'image de marque
y avait quand même tout un côté légende
qui qui joue beaucoup quand on veut
écrire des livres c'est qu'on pense
forcément à sagan si on veut écrire à 18
ans imagine que ça va être les voitures
rapides whisky toute la nuit il est
écrivant même plus leurs pires bay
permis de conduire
c'est dramatique se tue en voiture de
nuit mines ans s'est alors j'ai dit me
ou comme albert camus sépare impensable
ah ouais bah surtout avec la limitation
de vitesse à 30 à l'heure faut être très
fort pour se tuer en voiture mais mais à
part ça ça c'est l'ambiance c'est sûr
que l'ambiance a changé c'est des
problèmes m il ya moins de jolies femmes
dans les cocktails littéraire ça c'est
sûr aussi
elles étaient plus nombreuses à l'époque
mais la façon de trouver des écrivains
de les publier c'est totalement
différent oui j'ai l'impression qu'il y
en a beaucoup moins qu'avant peut-être
que le pourtant on en publie six ans
chacun aimerait pour pour payer le
salaire de la standardiste j'imagine et
puis il ya peut-être beaucoup moins dans
vie chez les gamins d'écrire des livres
aussi c'est ça fait plus partie de leur
mentalité le talent doit se réfugier
dans d'autres domaines parce que moi je
crois pas du tout à l'auteur modi'in
quelqu'un qui a
un tout petit talent il est forcément
publié par quelqu'un ça oui le génie
méconnu ça c'est un mythe mais ça
c'est peut-être en train de s'effacer
mais de toute façon c'est pas grave
parce que la littérature c'est fait pour
aux 5000 personnes maximum et tout le
reste après c'est un malentendu
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les
écrivains de votre génération doute de
leur petit hérité qu'ils aient du talent
ou pas mais le rêve de l'écrivain c'est
d'être lu encore quand il n'ira pas déjà
de leur présence
j'ai souvent vu qu ils doutaient de leur
postérité mais en s'abritant derrière
l'idée que au fond après eux on ne lira
plus donc toute façon ne les lira plus
non plus créé ouais enfin la modestie
n'est pas leur fort hein j'adore mais
celle excuses et hausse est une excuse
mais peut-être on ne sait pas il ya
quand on regarde les listes des
meilleures ventes des années 70 il ya un
tas de gens qui ont compté tellement
serviable qui sert et c'est ça qui est
marrant d'enseignés parce qu'il ya la
loterie posthume oms il sait mais par
exemple je me souviens pas quand j'ai
débuté on retrouvait tout le temps des
auteurs oubliés comme henri calet
raymond guérin paul gadenne aujourd'hui
ça n'existe plus du tout ça oui c'est
vrai il ya plus de réévaluation c'est
c'est triste quand même enfin c'est
peut-être un discours de vieux gâteux
mais peut-être que on avait déjà on en
avait tellement publié ensuite que il ya
plus personne à réhabiliter c'est plutôt
effectivement les gens qui disparaissent
j'aurais dernier est extrêmement présent
à partir du moment où il est mort une
impression tous ses ennemis ont gagné
ouais elle a souhaité parce que les
sharks revenir à jean edern hallier
abbas espère parce qu'il ment comment
aider t'emmerde ans comme la fumée mais
au moins il se crée le plat de nouilles
ça existait aujourd'hui a quand même une
espèce de chape de plomb de frilosité
plus personne n'ose amusé alors que
j'aurais dern c'était le plus personne
ne s'amuse eméyé il joue encore
s'engueuler mais c'est plutôt les
intellectuels c'est pas tellement les
écrits bruits c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu être un roman parce que pour moi
c'est le genre par excellence si on veut
défendre la l'édition il faut écrire des
romans parce que c'est ça c'est le les
anglo saxons continue à en faire deux
merveilleux et nous on a un peu
abandonnée sauf au profit de
l'auto-fiction des faits divers romancée
ou des biographies romancées
plus on se met dans la peau de marilyn
monroe se fait dans la foulée garner et
on raconte - lagardère ça a été bien au
début avec joyce carol oates mais
ensuite ça a fait des dégâts c'est
désolant
mais votre ami farid bbd lui s'est mis à
la place de challenger ouais c'est pas
un mauvais exemple et d'ailleurs il sort
un livre est très très bon en ce moment
lui aussi et il fait partie des gens qui
défendent le roman les livres en papier
et c'est peut être la nostalgie mais les
livres papier ils sont tous en papier et
le livre numérique c'est quand même
heureusement ça ne marche pas très bien
en france d'ailleurs vous assistez
c'est une maison d'édition qui 2 qui ne
peut ne lit pas les manuscrits envoyés
par mail bref c'est quoi le problème du
manuscrit envoyé pas mal on a calé à la
prime est avec ses photocopieurs canon
ça veut dire que la personne qui l'a
écrit n'y croit pas assez pour l'imprimé
ne fait pas cet effort là donc on
devrait lire et le fait de dit aussi
chez de maison qui donne n'envoie pas de
service de presse aux blogueurs ah oui
parce que ça va les trouver très
brillants les critiques littéraires dans
les journaux mais au moins il ya le
filtre du rédacteur en chef c'est pas du
tout pareil peut décrire comme ça
directement sur son écran en pensant
qu'on est un génie l'idée que quelqu'un
va vous lire avant que ce soit publié on
fait plus attention
vous avez des critiques particulièrement
indigente chez les blogueurs je les lis
pas j'avoue
mais il paraît que ça existe aussi m'a
tant mieux mais muet comme ils font des
critiques de théâtre des critiques de
cinéma non ma le soutiendrai un blog ça
voudrait vraiment dire que je suis au
bout du rouleau
il ya un moment faut arrêter si on peut
plus écrire dans les journaux plus
écrire de livres ça veut dire quoi on a
fait son temps on les animateurs télé le
bout du bout c'est le podcast
il est vraiment finie
mais vous vous avez un gros défaut c'est
que vous faites partie des animateurs
utilise qui savent de quoi on parle
c'est
un handicap sérieux oui oui enfin pour
moi ça va j'ai trouvé ce métier
intéressant
c'est quoi le moral de ce livre pour
vous parce que je vais chercher je n'ai
pas trouvé
ouais moi j'ai pas tellement normal dans
la vie dans les lilas mais non mais il
ya quand même il ya toujours l'idée qu'
on veut faire passer un message pas
forcément une
je voulais aller de la première à la
dernière phrase
ça continue un peu vous n'étiez pas
obligé de vous arrêter là assis là bas
parce que c'est la fin de quelque chose
le livre sur notre monde parce que c'est
mais il ya quelque chose qui va changer
ouais ouais oui oui mais ton nom c'est
bah c'est l'histoire d'un couple qui
finalement trouve très bien de rester
ensemble ouais c'est
donc vous êtes persuadé vous ce
que vous soupçonnez
tout un tas de chance tu es derrière
tous ces tracas que j'y crois pas tant
que ça s'ils sont philosophes
non son décès la sagesse pour viser des
romans igloo oui on dit souvent qu'avec
les femmes qui lisent des romans oui
pareil
au 19e non même aujourd'hui bah je suis
retrouvé à moi j'en ris
et j'aime beaucoup la nostalgie d'eric
je suis pas d'accord sur l'idée que
qu'il ya plus d'écrivains je trouve
qu'il ya alors j'ai dit que j'en avais
moi un oui ça comptait beaucoup moins
ouais je ne sais pas c'est disons qu'on
regarde un petit peu le passé
dit faire peut-être qu'il faut attendre
une vingtaine d'années pour comprendre
la richesse de des écrivains du début
des années 2000 mais oui je sais pas je
te jure je trouve qu'il ya je trouve
qu'il ya quand même des d'excellents
auteurs aujourd'hui
après le drame de tout ça c'est un
argument commercial à la base de tout
quoi évidemment peut-être que ça ça a
changé ça devait être la même chose mais
il y a toujours eu cet argument de toute
façon quoi alors
la nostalgie c'est toujours par rapport
à un moment donné quoi c'est
contextualiser clients mais on a surtout
l'impression qu'à toutes les époques il
ya des écrivains qui ont trôné qui
n'étaient pas des écrivains et qui
exhale curité oublier assez vite et puis
des écrivains qui avait beaucoup de
talent et que l'époque personne nous pas
grand monde prenait au sérieux et qui
est qui ont survécu ouais mais ça
c'était à l'époque où on s'intéressait
encore vraiment vu l'avion postérité
ouais là la résurrection des gens
méconnu qui croient de moins en moins
hélas non mais sans blague c'est je vois
pas que l'équivalent de ce que faisait
le dilettante dans les années 80 de
ressortir comme on disait calais des
gens comme ça aujourd'hui mais c'est
absolument impossible sinon on leur
pardon par exemple à un auteur
devenu célèbre en ressort c'est premier
ressort ses premiers textes souvent je
viens de terminer une nouvelle de
nicolas mathieu par exemple qui avait
été refusée à peu près partout je crois
d'abord et puis et puis qu'est-ce
qu'elle est très bonne nederland depuis
les prix goncourt et voilà et voilà
c'est ça mais est ce que les prix
goncourt auront une postérité
pas tous en tout cas le roman s'intitule
e rentrée littéraire il vient de
paraître chez albin michel ont fait une
pause on se retrouve juste après avec
olivier goujon direction pitcairn
[Musique]
diego juan vous êtes journaliste vous
publié chez max milo pitcairn les
révoltés du bounty vont disparaître vous
êtes rendu dans cette île mythique au
milieu du pacifique et 2000 km de tahiti
2000 km de l'île de pâques où on réussit
à se cacher les célèbres mutinés du
bounty en 1790 deux siècles plus tard ce
sont encore leurs descendants qui
l'habitent à quoi ressemble-t-il ce
caillou volcaniques
on va on va le voir en photo puis
calmez-vous tel que vous l'avez
découvert il ressemble effectivement un
caillou volcanique c'est à dire que
quand on arrive à pitcairn on voit
sortir l'île vraiment comme je le dis
dans le livre à l'aube parce que le
cargo qui part de mangareva qui met
trois jours et trois nuits pour aller
jusque là il arrive à l'aube donc on
voit sortir l'île à l'aube et s'est
tassée et elles ressemblent à ce pont du
voir les mutinés du boudin comme celle
amassée lille n'a pas bougé c'est à dire
il n'y a pas eu de superstructures et on
n'a pas construit on voit pas tout de
suite les petites maisons qui sont
cachés dans dans la jungle donc l'idée
c'était justement c'est c'est quelque
chose de très fort quand on arrive et
qu'on se dit je vois la même j'ai la
même vision que ce qu'ont vu les oeuvres
marins et les pontiques en fait c'est le
bout de terre le plus éloigné de toutes
les autres terre sur la planète qu'ils
auraient eu la chance de tomber sur
l'endroit le plus éloigné de toutes les
terres de la planète mais j'ai pas
retrouvé la confirmation je suis pas
certain non halal c'est sainte hélène
oui alors plus que sainte hélène ça
s'est su à ces fumées
je ne suis pas certain à ces concours là
ce qui est certain c'est que ils
s'installent là parce qu'ils
s'aperçoivent que lille est mal
cartographiée c'est à dire que sur les
cartes du de la marine anglaise du rhône
portsmouth les picards n'est située 200
miles au nord est ils sont surpris de la
trouver là donc qui se disent si on
s'installe la
retrouver on ira le chercher ailleurs et
donc qui s'installent là parce qu'ils
ont aussi avant de s'installer à tubuai
se sont fait virer par m alors revenons
sur sur la fameuse mutinerie elle a lieu
en 1789 il ya eu de nombreux films on va
en voir les affiches derrière moi il ya
le film avec carole finances 8e
chef-d'oeuvre avec kage blé et charles
laughton et puis après il ya ballon
bordeaux puis appuyez mel gibson là
c'est la version de brando au début des
années 60 bon c'est une histoire
formidable les l'histoire débute iliz du
bounty
raconte alléno puisque vous la
connaissez mieux que personne maintenant
c'est une histoire formidable et je le
dis dans le livre elle est vraiment
c'est frappant pourquoi elle a autant
[Musique]
marquer nos imaginaires c'est parce que
au fond c'est une séquence religieuse
est une allégorie biblique exactement
exactement c'est à dire
rébellion
péché punition pardon rédemption et
c'est ça qui se passe quand ils sont
alors qu'il ya la rébellion quand il
sort il se rebelle contre leur quinzaine
contre tyrannique en fait vous dit non
mais ça c'est un vrai enfin c'est là que
c'était pas moi il n'était pas si pire a
dit que je n'étais même pas du tout il
débute au même il était plutôt ça aurait
été un temps été un capitaine de gauche
c'est à dire que non mais c'était aussi
un productiviste entre guillemets c'est
à dire que s'il avait compris que pour
faire marcher les bateaux il fallait
préserver son équipage donc par exemple
y distribuer enfin les marins du parti
manger bien mais mieux plus ou moins
qu'ailleurs la légende c'est qu'il était
très tyrannique des très bons marins il
leur a fait subir un enfer et que son
second fletcher christian s'est rebellé
avec un certain nombre d'entre eux alors
qu'ils étaient arrivés à tahiti vous
faut dire c'était le paradis et que donc
ils l'ont ils ont laissé il est quand
même réussi à rentrer tout seul sans son
exploit dans l'histoire de deux de la
marine le capitaine bligh donc je crois
qu'on a une image du captain leïla c'est
le moment où il se rebelle contre lui
c'est réussi à rejoindre
batavia d'abord d'abord ils essaient de
débarquer dans une petite île du timor
et puis se font virer passe par des
parts des habitants de l'île qui veulent
pas d'eux donc il remonte même et sans
même avoir pu boire une goutte d'eau il
remonte sur leur canot tpir parties
finissent par arriver à batavia et de
batavia et repartent en angleterre
blight essaye de réarmer pour repartir
lui-même à y venir achever volé retrouvé
à quelque chose de personnel ou quoi
mais et une mutinerie c'est horrible ben
voilà s'il est atteint dans son honneur
il est lavé
c'est à dire qu'il passe en au tribunal
il est acquitté blight mais c'est pas
lui qui
sait pas lui qui retournent les chercher
il ya une malédiction parce que le
bateau qui va retourner chercher ceux
qui sont restés à tahiti il va en
ramener quelques uns va faire naufrage
et c'était quelque chose d'être parent à
l'époque ça bah oui bah oui mais le ton
par terre on avait eu des tgv sur 2
revenir c'est toujours est il que les
mutinés vont d'abord resté à tahiti puis
vont quitter l'île parce qu'ils savent
que c'est là qu'on viendra les chercher
l époque faut six mois pour revenir en
angleterre donc ils ont un peu de temps
même plus que ça mais tout bois il
s'installe à tubuai d'abord
et puis là c'est pareil ils se font
éjecter et
dès le début christiane christiane il
hésite il sait pas s'il veut se révolter
ou papy de remporter par le mouvement en
fait la légende le mythe va faire de
fletcher christian n'a un héros alors
que c'est un anti héros c'est un lâche
il est mené par le est le héros qui
était sympa alors non évidemment et
c'est alors le héros ce que celui qui
fait vraiment l'exploit on a 10 et
blight bon toujours est il que
voilà il arrive à pitcairn et puis là
alors attention ils ont quand même
d'abord volé des femmes des tahitiennes
alors à tahiti ils veulent des femmes je
tiens question visiblement sa femme elle
était volontaire c'est sa volée rallye
c'est pas sûr qu'elle ait bien compris
ce qui allait se passer dans la suite
qui allaient plus jamais revenir à
tahiti voilà mes s'installa pitcairn
isolé on ne les retrouvera qu'en 10 808
je crois si je me suis bien le 1er août
2007 190 pendant 28 ans il ne voit
personne et est le premier qui arrive
sans 1808 et qu'est ce qu'ils retrouvent
alors il retourne oui parce que quand
ils arrivent la première chose qu'ils
font c'est se battre oui c'est nous qui
sont que 9 mai mais quand même ailier
elles étaient désertes le désert blanc
mais il ya des traces d'installation pas
très très ancienne mais quand ils
arrivent l'idée déserte
et puis commence par s'engueuler et puis
se battre même et on appelle ça les
guerres de pitcairn
parce qu'ils ont emmené des
polynésiennes et puis des polynésiens et
puis quand ils arrivent les neuf anglais
se partagent l'île et puis il veut rien
donner aux polynésiens donc donc les
polynésiens
ça les agace et
alors on tue quelque polynésien les
polynésiens vont tuer les marins il
reste plus que adams et un
les enfants
des idéaux des uns et des autres et
notamment la dynastie jeudi octobre qui
descendent de
2,2 fletcher christian et ils sont
toujours là et qui sont toujours à 200
en état sont ceux qui sont là descendent
tous de cette chaire christian john
adams queen talent mccoy enfin les
révoltés du bounty sauf la famille de
paul polman qui est lui un beachcomber
c'est à dire que son aïeul avait été
abandonné sur l'élan donné par une
baleinière ouais parce qu'à l'époque
quand vous étiez pas pourtant vous
abandonné sur une île il avait cru
qu'ils étaient désertes il est une
chance il s'est retrouvé dans une île
très peuplée
et alors aujourd'hui sont combien et ils
vilte quoi alors combien sont ils sont
une cinquantaine un peu moins y vivent
ils sont entièrement dépendant de la
couronne britannique c'est à dire qu'ils
vivent du cargo qu'apportent les
marchandises quoi est il vit et des
subventions de l'union européenne qui
ont disparu d'ailleurs depuis le bric
site oui oui oui mais ça ça allait à des
projets ça allait enfin je ne sais pas
de l'argent qui était mais disons que le
voilà tout ce qui arrive comme
nourriture comme subsides comme
traitement ça vient l'angleterre il ya
quelques toutes petites productions sur
l'île mais quand on développe pas
enfin qu'on dit qu'on développe et puis
en fait on ne développe pas lille
pourrait encore être autosuffisante elle
a été pendant très longtemps elle ne
sera plus jamais parce que ils
disparaissent mais sur l'île tout pousse
anciens ont fait un miel extraordinaire
et c'est vraiment une il puisque vous
allez vous c'est vraiment une île
paradisiaque où comme peut l'être mais
ça dit que c'est ou ça c'est un endroit
plutôt russe est rude roche ses plus
proches de tahiti que de l'idée qu'on se
fait tahiti passe quand on pense à
tahiti en général on pense à abu ras ou
à des atolls des tuamotu encore quality
c'est une île montagneuse avec des
plages de cailloux et de sable où il
enfin c'est quand même assez idyllique
mais
bah oui c'est un
jeu graphiquement ça se rapproche plus
des australes par exemple de l'archipel
des australes c'est une île montagneuse
très exposé il n'y a pas de beille a pas
deux il n'y a pas d'endroit où s'abriter
c'est pour ça qu'ils brûlent la bande
qui quand ils arrivent parce qu'ils
peuvent pas la cacher donc je pensais
que c'est un voyage sans retour et
c'est pas une île 13 hospitalière il ya
de l'eau il ya de la nourriture donc en
ce sens cela c'est d'un paradis
polynésiens si on veut c'est à dire
qu'on peut rester là et puis survivre
pendant des décennies est alors donc
quand je dis vive de quoi il y en a qui
sait certains sont devenus riches quand
même d'après ce que vous dites oui enfin
riche tout dépend de l'idée qu'on se
fait de la richesse mais en tout cas en
tout cas
prosper a
ils vivent
pendant des années je vous dis le lilas
était autosuffisante c'est à dire que le
mil ont été largement abandonnée par
l'angleterre c'est oublié oui pour deux
siècles personne ne s'en émeut c'est ça
il faut il faut bien comprendre que le
le colonialisme anglais un peu différent
du colonialisme français mais je n'ai
pas du tout de jugement moral là dedans
mais le colonialisme français s'assigne
souvent une mission quelque chose de
messianique c'est à dire que nous on va
porter la bonne parole à porter à porter
les lumières quoique colonialismes
anglais très
commerçant commerçants c'est à dire une
colline ça doit rendre de l'argent comme
et puis kern ne sert à rien pendant
pendant des années ça sert à rien quoi
on a ça mais c'est pas du tout rentable
quoi donc plus en plus ils l'ont habité
contre la couronne quasiment un an plus
en plus voilà je veux dire pitcairn se
fondent contre la couronne britannique
quoi donc il y avait quelque chose de
alors en 1828
comme ils sont agressés régulièrement
par des baleiniers américain ils
demandent dans une lettre il demande la
protection de
la couronne britannique qui leur accorde
en même temps qu'un
semi pardon
voilà pour les actes un moment il était
question racontez vous que la couronne
britannique cède l'administration de
l'île nouvelle zélande des york et plus
ça a été évoqué plusieurs fois ça a été
évoqué plusieurs fois et puis peut-être
par presque par faiblesse pas par
paresse administrative on a laissé le
fric et lorsque ce qui est drôle c'est
qu'on y voit là une île mythique du fait
de son histoire de l'histoire de ce2 de
cette mutinerie et de la façon dont
elles se terminent bien croit ton quand
on voit les films parce qu'on se dit bon
bah ils ont trouvé une île on les
retrouvera jamais formidable en fait on
s'aperçoit qu'ils vont s'entretuer
et qu'ils vont réussir quand même à ce
que leurs descendants continuent
d'habiter là loin de tout le monde à
l'abri quasiment des regards il ya
finalement ces deux journalistes qui au
début des années 30 publie le récit un
peu biblique résumé tout à l'heure qui
va donner le premier film avec errol
flynn puis celui avec un quart gemmell
qui va populariser dans le monde entier
l'histoire du bounty mais sans que
jamais on retourne à pitcairn pour
autant au fond c'est une île où personne
ne va et où ils sont quasiment les seuls
à vivre ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux et puis surtout alors ce que
vous racontez et qu'on découvre dans ce
livre c'est qu'il ya un énorme scandale
à la fin des années 90 qui éclatent
des dizaines de viol aurait été commis à
pitcairn par les habitants de pitcairn
sur les habitants de pitcairn notamment
sur les enfants des habitants de pitgam
d'espèces de plus grands scandales
sexuels avant weinstein dans le monde
anglo saxon nous on n'en a pas entendu
parler mais en angleterre c'est à vanves
einstein c'est pitcairn quoi tout à fait
c'est à dire que
on peut laisser tomber conditionnelle
céder les faits sont avérés il ya eu des
condamnations ils ont purgé là ils ont
purgé leur peine même si c'était des
peines légères
oui c'est à dire comme ils ont été
abandonnés pendant des décennies un
l'angleterre a feint d'ignorer ce qui
s'y passait c'est à dire qu'en réalité
je montre leur livre comment l
angleterre savait pertinemment ce qui se
passait parce que il y avait quand même
un maître d'école qui étaient envoyés il
y avait des voyageurs de passage il y
avait une administration quand même il y
avait au commissariat donc il ya des
rapports qui étaient régulièrement faits
au commissariat
et puis qui était lettre morte et puis
quand on n'a plus pu cacher ce qui s'y
passait où on a été obligé de s'y
intéresser parce que des médias s'y
intéressaient
bon ben là l'angleterre a saisi
l'occasion pour une reprise en main
coloniale de lille qui est à
cyniquement un coup de génie quoi c b
c'est fou comme piquionne on se dit
c'est au fond de cette petite entité
avec très peu de demandes aujourd'hui
sont plus que 40 25 ans ils ont été 2
100 moment je crois un essai récent
amendement ils sont 200 et il y en a 150
qui émigrent vers l'ue leur folk une île
au large de réalisme et ont dit aux
fossiles a résumé de la civilisation
tout vous le disiez quand ils arrivent
immédiatement les tahitiens sont spoliés
les blancs ce partage tout évidemment
les tahitiens se révoltent et tous ne
s'entretuent on s'entretue pour les
terres mais aussi pour les femmes enfin
à chaque fois ils leur arrivent en petit
ce qui vous arrive et là on peut
imaginer que des gens qui vivent comme
ça entre eux depuis depuis deux siècles
qui se reproduisent doivent avoir des
rapports quand même très particulier
c'est c'est une c'est exactement ça en
fait c'est une réduction c'est une
réduction de 2 de notre histoire de
notre sociologie de deux noms de nos
défauts de nos qualités et nos défauts
et de nos qualités exactement c'est une
comédie humaine
en réduction c'est une comédie humaine à
la fois dantesques et ordinaire
dantesque parce qu'on est au bout du
monde dans des circonstances et dans un
contexte hallucinant et puis ordinaire
parce que
le crime malheureusement et les crimes
qui vont s'y dérouler s'y déroulent
partout se diront par exemple que moi
aussi je fais dans le pacifique je suis
pas allée avec picarde déchets aller
dans des îles comme ça c'est quand même
quelque chose de très particulier même
dans l'atlantique on vit pas ça c'est à
dire que c'est c'est on se sent
minuscule pas certain que c'est beaucoup
plus grand que l'atlantique c'est
beaucoup plus grand que tout est à dire
que toute la surface de la terre si vous
plantez une épingle pour aller de
l'autre côté vous tomberez dans le
pacifique pour vous dire à quel point
ces grands il n'y a pas un pays
quasiment qui qui qui ne tombe pas dans
le dans le pacifique quand on retourne
le globe
la voûte étoilée est absolument
invraisemblable on se sent absolument
minuscule ce j'imagine que vous avez
sorti la même chose dans n'y ajoute à
face est très juste c'est très juste il
ya une dimension de lui il ya une
dimension de l'immensité
qui dépasse qu'on peut connaître
ailleurs dans l'océan indien dans
l'océan dans l'océan il le fait de se
détruire une île bloqués s'est bloquée
oui c'est ça bloqué en même temps libre
une île c'est toujours à la fois une
prison et une porte et est donc ils sont
ils sont bloqués ils savent mais ils
savent depuis le début que leur leur
destin est en dehors de l'humanité
qu'ils ont connu en tout cas et ils ont
mis leurs propres règles et essayer les
accès sont on s'aperçoit quand quand il
ya ces affaires qui sortent des dizaines
de viols dont certains sur des enfants
et il a fait divers sur des enfants mais
le
vous dites que vous faites le viol était
été puni à pizza menée uniquement sur
les enfants sinon en gros il n'y a pas
de texte qui interdit de violer la femme
du voisin c'est je sais juste c'est
juste et alors ils ont émis ils ont
produit leurs propres législations et
c'est d'ailleurs ça qu'ils ont opposé à
la couronne anglaise quand la couronne
anglaise a dit devant les pressions
médiatiques l'angleterre a dit s'il ya
eu une enquête du gars d'en face je
renvoie au livre pour ça
l'enquêté hallucinante d'ailleurs parce
que c'est des pirates un don qui se
laisse pas faire et ceux enfin à mon
dieu ils tendent des pièges aux juges
c'est un truc assez et puis surtout
quand les anglais leur dise bon ben on
va appliquer la loi 19 heures ils disent
non parce que nous on n'est pas en
guerre on épie carner mélomanes et aux
lois voilà on a nos lois et alors un
viol c'est puni de deux moineaux je
crois comme qu'ivresse
donc ils ont des lois très particulière
mais ils disent c'est nos lois et on est
une nation et d'ailleurs du point de vue
des règles édictées par l'onu par
exemple qui sont une nation c'est à dire
que ils ont ils ont langue ils ont une
histoire ils ont un désir de vivre
ensemble même si c'est un désir
polémique je veux dire c'est que ya des
rivalités qui peuvent se détester les
uns les autres tout à fait mais irait
pas vivre ailleurs et donc ils
constituent une une nation à tous les
effets c'est ça qui vont opposer à la
couronne britannique en leur disant ben
vous n'avez pas nous juger puisque
d'ailleurs vous nous avez abandonnés
nous sommes une nation et en plus nous
sommes une nation polynésienne et en
polynésie on a des traditions de mariage
avec afin d'avoir des relations
sexuelles dans ce qui est complètement
de mauvaise foi c'est existe nulle part
en polynésie ailleurs mais vous dites
aussi que si on regarde les actes de
naissance de des pics carner les femmes
tombent enceintes entre 12 et 15 ans
avant avaya pas une femme qui arrive
vierge à l'âge de il n'y a pas une jeune
fille qui à part dans qui arrive vierge
l'âge de 11 ans en général sont mariés
des enfants naissent enfin il suffisait
de conte de compte il suffisait de
regarder le registre des mariages de
pitcairn qui était au commissariat en
nouvelle zélande pour s'apercevoir que
il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas quoi donc c'est bien la preuve que
l'angleterre a fermé les yeux quoi oui
m'enfin imaginer une île où il y aurait
que des enfants ils se marieraient tous
à 12 ans et et il n'y aurait pas de
problèmes tant que vous aimez non qu'ils
aient fait pas des adultes bien sûr sauf
que les enfants enfin je veux dire
c'était clairement des viols y avait
c'était clairement des viols et puis ça
c'est ce qu'on a pu juger mais ce qu'on
a découvert a été c'est la partie
émergée de l'iceberg si vous voulez mais
on a découvert des abus sur des enfants
de beaucoup beaucoup plus jeune et des
choses terrifiantes et alors quand vous
dites aujourd'hui que lee fait que les
révoltés du bounty vous disparaître il
sondé les vraies leçons des ans disparu
depuis le long temps mais les
descendants pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
de moins en moins nombreux donc ils sont
de plus en plus vieux cette affaire a eu
des conséquences
peu de gens gmail vides ont envie
d'aller s'installer à pitcairn non
détrompez vous c'est justement
justement alors ça c'est ce que dit
c'est ce que dit l'angleterre 10
personne ne veut y aller en fait
c'est pas vrai ils ont des centaines de
dossiers chaque année c'est difficile à
évaluer parce que le haut-commissariat
communique pas là dessus mais il ya des
centaines de dossiers chaque année moi
j'ai évalué sa autour de 8000 jeu je
montre le calcul dans le livre et aucun
ace jamais accepté quelques uns parfois
je cite l'exemple de la famille manson
ou alors des timings et mais reste pas
il reste pas parce que le haut
commissariat les aide pas vraiment
et puis les picards ne veulent pas
partager c'est très clairement quoi est
donc en fait c'est nous réduction on à
l'europe sawiris au vieux ils sont vieux
ils ont peur qu'on leur pique leur job
disant voir bien ils vont mourir mais
ils veulent pas ils veulent surtout pas
d'immigrés alors c'est ça héhé
et donc très clairement les enfants s'en
vont les vieux meurt personnes
n'arrivent ils vont mourir c'est
intéressant générer ou pas non non non
regardez là on va nous remettre la vie
de la couverture va la regarder belle
tête r on dirait un joueur de rugby
saleh a dit la picarde
le petit quart d'heure
ils sont pas tous aussi mais à typer
mais enfin on comprend que les anglais
aient dit bon on ne touche pas en voyant
des gars comme ça mais en même temps
c'est un peu la revanche de l'angleterre
c'est exact au fond c'est il était comme
une espèce était de 10 on peut sentir
bafouée par ces mutins qui avaient
réussi à leur échapper qui avait fondé
une colonie qui avaient prospéré qui
durait encore hélas c'est formidable
regardez ce que ça donne quand on quitte
le giron de l'angleterre deux cent
trente ans après les mutins sont enfin
punis ouais
alors vous raconter qu'il ya aussi il ya
un moment le descendant du capitaine
bligh qui vient et qui fait don il avait
killed avec un livre quand il veut et
quand il veut se sont mutinés c'était la
bible du capitaine bligh et c'est à
partir de cette bible que fletcher
christian rendait la justice etc etc
c'est donc très important de cette bible
est le descendant du capitaine bligh est
venu en faire don officiellement
puisqu'elle lui avait été volé devenue
un enfer doit officiellement aux
descendants de fletcher question c'est
ça et enfin la cérémonie s'est passé en
australie mais l'arrivée mais il a
retrouvé jacques et christiane là en
australie et il a officiellement donné
la bible donné la bible qu on peut voir
du petit musée de pitcairn à adam star
sur les lucquois en fait aujourd'hui
quoi alors en général les habitants
pitcairn déteste les livres les
documentaires les articles qui sont
écrits sur pitgam qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils vont penser de votre livre
avoue
papa du bien enfin ça dépend ça dépend
qui parce que
mois pour écrire le livre évidemment je
suis resté en contact avec des pics
quart nord est
disons que disons qu'ils sont déchirés
puis ils ont été déchirées par ce qui
s'est passé parce que la plupart des
hommes ont participé à ça et même
l'immense majorité mais certains noms et
notamment par le pôle est celui qui est
surtout celui qui est sur la couv
donc en fait mais c'est ça aussi ça
renvoie ça le l'angleterre avait
plusieurs avait un choix à faire pour
régler ce cette situation pour régler ce
problème l'angleterre a choisi la
manière forte médiatique et puis au bout
du compte à donner des peines qui était
vraiment ridicule
mais la manière forte médiatique c'est à
dire que la baronne scotland a dit c'est
insupportable on peut pas accepter ça
enfin comme si c'est enfin il le savait
depuis longtemps mais bon
il avait une autre façon de faire qui
était un processus de réconciliation qui
est
politique est à la fois qui permet de se
projeter dans l'avenir c'est ce qu'on a
fait en afrique du sud ou au rwanda par
exemple s'était confronté les bourreaux
et leurs victimes et puis à partir de là
initiés quelque chose qui allait les
projeter ensemble dans l'avenir sas a
pas du tout été fait il ya que les
africains qu'ils savent faire ça j'ai
jamais les europe et ses coéquipiers
mais personne n'a fait ça a peint les
africains c'est les seuls qui savent le
faire en tout cas c'est codifié à l'onu
et on aurait pu au moins essayer cette
cette voie là parce que le résultat
c'est que aujourd'hui tout le monde se
déteste et puis chacun replier sur ses
prérogatives
tout le monde sait que tout le monde va
mourir mais personne ne fera l'effort de
enfin je veux dire
tout le monde se laisse mourir quoi donc
oui le livre sera pas très bien
accueillie dans une partie de la
population qui mieux ailleurs
voilà
c'est vous regarderez les films
autrement maintenant à deux filets c'est
aussi consanguins l'édition 7 il
comptait rassurer vos le temps qui
viennent à paris ve pour vous orgueil
ben surtout en ce moment parce qu'ils
n'ont pas eu quatre commis d'un aaa
donc il est complètement fermée en temps
normal on accède à livre à lille une
dizaine de fois par an par margot de
paris en tout c'est très compliqué le
plus long c'est d'abord obtenir les
autorisations parce que il faut
l'autorisation du conseil de lille et du
haut-commissariat pisan donne pu surtout
à la presse et
bon une fois qu'on a ça il faut des mois
pour avoir ça une fois qu'on a ça il
faut aller à mangareva que déjà le
gambier c'est l'archipel le plus est de
polynésie française qui a aucun biais à
mangareva il faut attendre le clae mort
qui arrive de nouvelle zélande une
dizaine de fois par an et apprécier
trois jours trois nuits de cargos pour
piquer ils ont demandé pendant des
années un petit aéroport nous aurait pu
laisser les gens qui ont dit non alors
que c'était le moyen d'exporter de la
pêche et des kiwis du miel enfin des
petites exportations qui est qui était
une manière pour eux de 2,2 de vivre
encore et puis de produire dans l'île
quoi
et puis de maintenir dans le temps leur
identité
profonde afin de rester de pitié parce
qu'aujourd'hui même s'il y devient un
paradis pour milliardaires ou une base
militaire n'importe quoi enfin de toute
façon ce sera jamais avec eux ça c'est
sûr
merci olivier goujon le livre s'intitule
beat kern les révoltés du bounty vont
disparaître il est paru chez max milo
bercy eric neuhoff rentrée littéraire
c'est paru chez albin michel merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]